new video evidence led to more than a
hundred and fifty new charges in the
deaths of a Penn State student after an
alleged hazing ritual five fraternity
brothers are now charged with felonies
and Timothy Piazza's death a total of 26
faced criminal charges
Anna Werner is outside the fraternity
house in State College Pennsylvania she
spoke with Piazza's parents and a good
morning good morning so the FBI was able
to recover that surveillance video from
the basement of this fraternity house
initially fraternity members told
detectives that the camera down there
was not working but now that new video
means more young men are facing new
charges
police say the restored security footage
from the fraternity house basement shows
Timothy Piazza consuming at least 18
drinks in 82 minutes this is a very
important situation District Attorney
Stacey Parks Miller says not once did
the 19 year old get alcohol on his own
Beta Theta Pi brothers gave Piazza all
of his drinks we believe the behavior
was reckless and that people could
foresee serious bodily injury and death
from the culmination of this behavior
she charged 22-year old Braxton Becker
with tampering with evidence for
allegedly deleting the basement video
while police were searching in the
fraternity house and then he sent it to
the FBI and they in fact confirmed it
was deleted and were able to recover it
Tim's parents Jim and Evelyn Piazza what
does it mean to you to have new charges
filed and to have that video be
recovered well I think having the video
recovered just kind of shows the the
type of mindset that went on in that
house like they could get away with it
his life mattered it should have
mattered to all of them prosecutors
filed more than 150 new charges Monday
including involuntary manslaughter
aggravated assault
hazing and furnishing alcohol to minors
five defendants face felonies among the
12 new fraternity members charged Joseph
M's misdemeanor charge was dismissed by
the judge in September but he's now
charged again with hazing furnishing
alcohol to minors and unlawful acts
relative to liquor his attorney William
J Brennan has not yet seen the new video
we successfully defended this case once
we thought it was
behind us but we'll suit up and do it
again if need be
Piazza died in February following what
prosecutors described as an
alcohol-fueled hazing ritual that
started in the basement I don't know
that as an adult who has had drinks all
his life I'd be able to to tolerate one
third of that not even a quarter Tom
Klein is the Piazza family's attorney
the videotape is going to be the
ancillary evidence which is going to
likely convict individuals it was the
missing link in proving what happened we
reached out to attorneys for the
defendants charged yesterday we heard
back from two of them lawyers for Gary
de billy-oh and Michael by to tell us
that their clients are not responsible
for Tim piazzas death charly
Anna thanks